Hello Freak bitches.
I know a dude who thought he was buying a stereo,
but he's actually buying bricks.
He got one of those stereotypes.
He's a fucking half a month ago.
He stopped at the street and bought from a guy named Jamal.
I had a guy,
I was buying pet food.
I pulled into this parking spot.
I got out and this dude literally opened the van like he was going to take me in
and fuck me.
Like I was like some little kid.
He was about to scoop up out of the woods like it was a molester and I'm like,
what?
Like what do you,
what do you got?
And he's like,
stereotypes,
you want buy stereo.
I was like,
this is the weirdest.
He's.
He opened up the door like as people parked the car and it was literally like,
go,
hey man,
you want some of this?
Like what?
You're asking for trouble if you do business one of those guys,
most obvious shit ever.
You know,
he's just randomly trying to sell a stereo to the back of a van.
Now.
What are these things that they do in whatever?
Like the people go when they have,
what do they junk junkets.
Junkets.
No,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
The thing off the fucking five,
the you always see in the movies and all the fucking Friday they all go to a
place and they,
they,
they buy stereos and raider hats.
Swap swap me.
Oh yeah.
Well in that way it's a swap meet in Jersey that called,
what do they call you?
Market?
Something like that.
When I was a kid I used to go to where they used to do the bicycles,
whatever those street car races and next door to it they had what was called and
you'd go there and they had pretty much shit that was stolen.
It was just a festival and they tries to a table fee because everything was 50
percent off.
Even the sneakers I remember and then we found that that the guy would go to the
fucking factory and jump over the fence and take over
the sneakers.
No mistakes.
Irregulars he,
they would take those and just sell them at those swap swap meets.
And then we found that we cut into his action.
I just want it gone.
We,
we,
we cut into that action and the action limit,
those tubes are blocked.
Best Prank,
they would throw thousands of amount with little things like the chemical was
off.
You start blinking too much,
like the chemical.
Then it was pepper spray,
pepper spray,
like people would spray it and you can see what happened.
It's not regular,
but Naka.
What does that tear gas.
It was like the tickets.
This band is good.
That was afterthought and we make them jump the fence and we'd have thousands of
tubes and we'd sell them for fifty cents a piece on Monday the sixth and seventh
grade I virus,
but there wasn't always three kids that complain.
There was a little like the chemical imbalances
I've been saying for awhile,
but I think Caitlyn Jenner created Donald Trump.
Not really,
but it created this thing.
I mean,
I think there was a thing,
there was a tipping point and for me it was when they gave her a woman of the
year and Glamour magazine and then Espn gave her as an athlete of the year and
when we're that ridiculous thing that they did where they circled her house,
so the helicopter and she was hiding behind the curtains and it was all
mysterious like why in the fuck are you selling?
Like what is this?
And for people at home that are like in Indiana and they're drinking beer and
they like football and they went to watch the sbs to see who won best
quarterback of the year and they're seeing that kind of shit.
They're like,
what the fuck is as we need to make America great again.
You know,
I never linked it that specifically,
but I think you're totally right.
Even right now when I've been watching the NBA season just started and I love
basketball.
Every time I turn on TNT now it's Barkley and Kenny Smith and Shaq and Ernie
Johnson talking about race.
They're not talking about basketball.
They're talking about race.
They're talking about policing,
those are all important issues to talk about,
but people go to sports for the release,
they go to sports because they care about that leads and what's happening on the
field and in the,
in the box and imagine whatever it is and now everything is becoming
politicized.
So espn is giving their athlete of the year to Caitlyn Jenner.
It makes no freaking sense.
Well,
that was a white nfl ratings down.
You know,
it's because people are talking about Kaepernick and politics instead of sports.
Does that make the ratings go down?
Really is the ratings.
The ratings are hugely down in the NFL this year and a lot of people are linking
that.
I don't know it empirically.
I wouldn't be shocked.
There's a lot of people in this country just have zero tolerance.
I mean it's almost like separation of church and state.
They would like their sports to just be sports and about sports.
Yeah.
You know,
and I,
I kind of appreciate that in a certain way because it's like if you were
watching a comedy show and all of a sudden during that comedy show they started
deeply discussing religion and like really like discussing deep intricacies of
different faith based cultures.
You'd be like,
what the fuck am I want?
This is not comedy do is funny.
But once you heard in that thing and now you're doing something else right,
you're doing a different thing.
You're not doing sports,
you're doing,
you're doing race relations,
are you doing?
But I don't understand that.
It's also they look at it as a platform for our culture and that's what
Kaepernick did.
He said,
look,
I have this platform.
And in some ways I think what he did kind of worked because a lot of kids in
high school now are doing that.
They're taking knees and the national,
you know,
when they do the national anthem,
it's strange,
but it's also like the black,
uh,
like when people have the black fist at the Olympics,
who,
those dudes that did that in the 19 seven,
I think it was 71.
Maybe something like that.
Whatever that was.
I mean that got people talk and this gets people talking to and maybe sometimes
you need to kind of inject some sort of something to think about during sporting
events.
I'm not telling them not to do it.
Of course I would.
Net cabernet wants to do that.
Go ahead.
These guys,
if,
if Barkley and all that one,
if they're tnt bosses are okay with it and they go,
well,
you know,
you can do that.
Instead of talking about how many points Duran had been,
so be it,
but I'm just saying what I think most people want from sports is an escape.
And I can tell you for sure in the two or three at the NBA season has been
gone.
Every time I flipped by TNT and they're doing that,
I change it.
When those homeless people were breaking in my house,
joy drove by every night.
How many homeless people broke into your house?
A couple.
Really because we were under construction.
We're renovating.
Oh No.
First one broke in a Brumby's.
Very similar.
You can't scare them.
Really?
Yeah.
I was sitting.
I.
We had dinner at my sister's house.
The girls went inside.
Everything's under construction.
We've got like a big dumpster out front.
It looks like it's under construction and I'm sitting off to the side smoking a
cigar in the darkness and this girl just starts walking in,
walking up the driveway,
starts to go into our backyard and I see her and I'm like,
wait,
do I know?
I must know her.
It's a weird thing when you get robbed that you're like,
it's like a such a confrontation that you're like,
like if you ever been like been in conversation and someone's like,
hey man.
And you're like,
oh,
I must have this person high.
And then they attack you and you're like,
oh fuck.
This is how it starts.
That that was what happened in this girl was just going back here and I go and
we must know her and I go,
Hey,
can I help you?
And then she was like,
oh hey.
And she like said something like I work for the dwp or some child's organization
something.
And I was like,
no,
this is,
you're breaking into my backyard and I start fucking shouting at her and she
just keeps walking towards me.
She's not fucking scared at all.
Priscilla is 130 pound bull mastiff obese.
Have a fucking dog is going at her,
like leaping at her and all this.
Keeping up as a little tiny like dog fence that we had in our front yard at the
time.
Fearless this woman was.
You couldn't shake her hair.
I think a heroin addict probably.
Yeah.
And,
and I was like,
motherfuckers,
we call the cops.
Then the cops show up.
I don't remember when Shit's on cops.
I love them.
They showed up in three minutes.
They were there three minutes.
The woman had already taken off.
I told them where they were at.
She went and the guy was like,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
there's a new heroin dealer in town,
a lot of junkies and homeless people.
We're going to be loitering around here until we stopped that.
But he's like,
I'm sorry.
And I look and what both my daughters are in the,
um,
in the doorway and they're looking out and I'm like,
hey man,
I told the cops are good.
Do you mind if the girls come down for like two seconds and just let them know
that they'll be like,
you're going to do,
there's nothing to worry about.
And he's like getting all your girls gone down.
So Georgia highly come down and they'd had lollipops and they put notes on it
that said,
you are our heroes.
And they gave him to the cops.
I'm me talking about a heart breaking moment.
These costs were like,
ladies.
Well first of all we will be circling this bark all night long.
Nothing's happened to his house.
We will keep an extra good.
I out in this house in Georgia,
starts pulling on my shirt.
She's like,
Dad,
let's go dad,
let's go.
I was like,
hold on George,
he's not done.
He's just like,
Dad,
dad,
I think we can.
We should go to the house.
And I was like,
Georgia,
it's fine by the guy gives a speech and we walked back to the house and I was
wearing this shirt and she goes,
you are wearing a marijuana shirt.
Ah.
Was like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Cops don't give a fuck.
No.